[Music]
preferentially attaching yourself to
people that you resemble or who have
similar interest that you do for
instance a similar tolerance for heat
and cold or similar taste in foods for
example actually could confer a fitness
advantage so if you are following around
another person who gets cold at the same
temperature that you get cold that
person might build a fire and if they
build a fire they create this positive
externality they create this benefit for
you it would be better for you to be
near such a person than near a person
who had a different heat tolerance than
you did or for example if if there were
different kinds of foods in the
environment some of which made you sick
being with people who resembled you in
their tolerance for those foods would be
advantageous because they would go to an
environment where they could eat the
food and so could you eat the food so
hanging out with people you resemble is
a kind of a way of probing your match
with the environment
if you preferentially attach to people
that you resemble you will therefore be
more likely to be in an environment
which is good for you
another idea has to do with the kind of
multiplicative advantages of certain
kinds of genotypes what do I mean by
that well imagine a kind of toy idea
kind of toy model in which you are the
first person on the planet to evolve the
capacity for speech there's big debate
right now about a particular gene called
fox p2 some people think it plays a role
in our evolution or speech some don't
but imagine that it does for the sake of
argument imagine you are the first
person on the planet to have a mutation
in this gene which confers in you the
capacity for speech this mutation would
be useless to you unless you had the
connected to someone you could talk to
it would be a little bit like being the
first person on the planet to get an
email address the email address is
useless to you unless you have someone
to email then all of a sudden it becomes
very advantageous so this example too is
an example of why we might have evolved
the capacity or the interest in
preferentially hanging out with people
that we resemble and there are a number
of advantages and disadvantages to this
tendency once it arises the advantages
include some of the things we've already
talked about
but they also include the ability of a
group of people of shared abilities and
interests to bond and work together to
achieve common objectives so for example
if I can hang out with people I resemble
who have similar tastes and abilities
that I do I kind of know on what to
count on you know if we're going out to
hunt big game and we all can run at the
same speed I kind of know that this
group can move at this pace for instance
but their disadvantages it well be as
well because once you form a group of
people who all resemble each other
you have no heterogeneity in skills
maybe what you really need is a group or
one person is is it can see far and can
spot the prey and another person is
strong and can spear the prey and or
maybe you want heterogeneity of
information when you have groups that
are all very similar to each other when
groups form you get a kind of redundancy
of information and no novelty everyone
is like do you know where the prey item
is do you know where the prey item is
everyone has the same information but
you would rather have a group of people
with different knowledge and different
skills who might be able to work
together to achieve common objectives so
natural selection across our evolution
has taken account of these advantages
and has shaped us too in general prefer
homophony
but we don't always prefer homophily
there's this notion of you know birds of
a feather flock together but we also
have in our language this notion of
opposites attract so we are also
equipped with the capacity to define the
borders of our group and one of the ways
to push back against tribalism is to
step up from the tribalism and to
broaden the focus of our concern to
redefine the group as being even bigger
and if you think about this politically
in the United States for example one of
the one of the kind of political agendas
in our country since its founding in
with respect to the American project has
been to believe and claim I think
rightly so that anyone can be an
American the the focus of our tribalism
becomes our shared Americanism so you
can step up from individual groups and
sort of be united by our
humanity or in this case our common
nationality and broaden the focus but in
addition we have this other ability we
have this ability to step down and look
at the level of individuals we have the
capacity to express and detect
individual identity we do this with our
faces every human knows that they can
look at a thousand faces until one
person from the other we signal our
individuality with our faces our faces
have evolved to be incredibly different
unlike our hands for example you can't
tell your friends apart by looking at
their hands but you can tell them
instantly apart by looking at their
faces and the fact that we can do this
the fact that we can see individuals as
unique is very important if you are for
instance and a baby and you want to
communicate to your mother or your
father this is me not someone else care
for me or if you want to support
cooperation you want you want the
ability to remember who was nice to you
and who is not nice to you the capacity
for signalling and detecting individual
identity is crucial for maintaining
cooperation in social systems same for
friendship its crucial and so to tell
your friends apart or to tell friends
from strangers you need to be able to
signal individual identity so individual
identity exists in our group in our in
our species it plays a role in all of
these things I'm discussing and it gives
us another way of counteracting
tribalism because now instead of
stepping up a level to redefine the
groups to be bigger we can also step
down a level and now look at individuals
not as members of groups but as unique
human beings so we don't need to rely on
this heuristic we don't need to allow on
this sort of this kind of convenient
tool of saying who should I be friend oh
I should be friend people who resemble
me or people who are members of my own
group we can either say I am open to
befriending anybody or we can say I'm
going to assess each person as a unique
human being when deciding whether to
hang out with them or not
[Music]